[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to today's webinar it's world
sepsis day today and we are very excited
to be here to present challenges in
sepsis
diagnostics and patient management i'm
dr jordan cardinal the u.s region
microbiology medical science liaison at
bd in our life sciences integrated
diagnostic solutions business unit i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bd
to learn more
feel free to visit bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions that we
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well
we've already gotten one question this
morning that i wanted to address dress
here in the introduction
we will plan on adding ce credits for
the on-demand portion of this program
they aren't applied to this live session
yet
it's my pleasure now to welcome our
speaker today dr pat murray
dr pat murray received his microbiology
ph.d at ucla before going on to
postgraduate training in clinical micro
at mayo clinic in rochester
he was the director of the clinical
microbiology lab at barnes jewish
hospital and professor of medicine and
pathology at washington university from
1976 to 1999.
in 99 he joined the faculty of the
university of maryland school of
medicine and in 2001
soon after he accepted the position of
senior scientist and chief of
microbiology at the national institutes
of health
in july 2011 he retired from the nih and
accepted a position at bd diagnostics as
vice president and worldwide
of worldwide scientific affairs and
that's where i had the pleasure to cross
paths with him
he did retire to artist may last year in
2021
he is still a fellow of the amer
american academy of microbiology and
ivsa and also a member of the clsi
consensus committee for antimicrobial
susceptibility standards he's the former
chairman of the american board of
medical microbiology for former chief in
editor-in-chief for the asm manual of
clinical microbiology and former editor
of journal of clinical microbiology he
still currently serves on numerous
editorial boards he's authored more than
275 research articles and 20 books he's
also the recipient of numerous awards
through his robust career and his
contributions to our field in patient
care research leadership and all of his
achievements it's our privilege to hear
from him today and learn more about
sepsis from the perspective of
diagnostics so thank you dr murray
thank you jordan for your for your kind
comments um as jordan mentioned i
retired
at the beginning of this year
uh from becton dickinson um so it was
very nice that they've invited me back
to uh to give this presentation
um
i
so let me hit the right button
um
uh because i retired they are paying me
an honorarium for my presentation but i
frankly would have done this anyway
because i think today is a very
important day
um i think
what i'd like to do is look at sepsis
and
try to put in a little bit of a
different perspective
many in the audience come from a
diagnostic field
or come from medicine where they rely
heavily on diagnostics
so i think it's important to understand
the value of diagnostics and the
limitations of diagnostics
i believe it's important also to start
with some definitions so when we talk
about bacteremia or fungi fungi we're
talking about the presence of bacteria
or fungi in the blood
a bloodstream infection then is a
positive blood culture in a patient with
systemic signs of infection and that may
either be primary that is from the blood
vessels themselves or secondary from an
infection such as a urinary tract
infection or pneumonia
sepsis is a life-threatening organ
dysfunction caused by the dysregulation
of the host's response to infection in
other words we overreact to the
infection and it creates some damage to
to one or more organs and if it's
multiple organs
we define that as septic shock
now there's some important facts that
i've listed here about sepsis i think
the important thing to keep in mind is
that it's common 49 million cases have
been reported each year with about 11
million deaths so it's a common disease
with a high mortality rate
it's the least leading cause of
mortality and critical illness worldwide
and when we look at hospital mortality
patients with sepsis have a 25 to 30
percent risk of not surviving that
infection there's a variety of risk
factors that are responsible for that
but one in particular i want to point
out is that there's a two-fold increase
in mortality when the wrong antibiotics
are given and why is that important
because selecting the appropriate
antibiotic requires good diagnostic
tests and so that underscores the value
of diagnostics the last point we don't
like to think always in terms of
medical illnesses and the cost of those
medical illnesses but i think it is
important to recognize that sepsis
is the leading cost
in hospitalized patients in the united
states attributing for more than 62
billion dollars of expenses each year so
not only is this a deadly disease as a
very costly disease
now in 2021 guidelines for managing
sepsis
were were issued this is an update from
previous guidelines
on the surface this is very similar to
what had been said before we want to
be able to identify septic patients as
early as possible or at least have a
suspicion they're septic
you use markers like lactate to help
ensure that that
early identification cultures become
very important not just blood cultures
but
cultures of other potential sites of
infection so we'll talk about that
for a little bit
antibiotics obviously are important in
an infected patient we want to make sure
we give them the appropriate antibiotics
and then fluids are necessary
to be able to one of the problems with
sepsis is that there's a lack of
diffusion of fluids into the organs
which causes the organs in the fail and
so fluids is an important component for
managing septic patients
i'm gonna in the next two slides i'm
gonna quote directly from the 2021
sepsis guidelines
to start off we recommend that
appropriate routine microbiologic
cultures including blood cultures should
be obtained
before starting antimicrobial therapy in
patients with suscept with suspected
sepsis and septic shock if this results
in no substantial delay in the start of
antimicrobials
what we do know is that anywhere from 28
to 63 percent of patients receive
antibiotics before those cultures are
collected and as i'll show in a later
slide this has a direct effect on the
success of those cultures
and we must weigh the use of cultures
and diagnostics and and and treatment
and to say that we don't want to delay
key therapy
from the same guidelines they actually
became much more specific than what we
had before
so
for adults
with possible septic shock
or a high likelihood for sepsis
the recommendation is to administer
antimicrobials immediately ideally
within one hour of recognition so if we
want to give cultures before antibiotics
this is a challenge for for us to be
able to collect the cultures in a timely
way
for adults with possible sepsis without
shock
we recommend rapid assessment of the
likelihood of infectious versus
non-infectious causes
and a time limited course of rapid
investigation
and if the concern for infection
persists the administration of
antimicrobials within three hours
from the time sepsis was first
recognized so without septic shock the
recommendation is the weight up to three
hours before antibiotics are
administered and finally for adults with
a low likelihood of infection and
without shock we suggest deferring
antimicrobials
while continuing to closely monitor the
patient
so this is a balance between diagnostics
treatment and really antimicrobial
stewardship to not over utilize
antibiotics when they're not necessary
so some of the diagnostic challenges in
most of my presentation i'm going to
talk about these challenges
our challenge is to collect the
microbiology specimen but the question
is what specimens have the highest
diagnostic yield
what's the most common sources of sepsis
and what are the challenges in
collecting the microbiology specimens
so if we
look at the broader picture
i think it's important that if you look
at a population of septic patients
anywhere from 20 to 54
will have documented bloodstream
infections that is we have a positive
blood culture
now if you think about it we're missing
as many as 80 percent of the patients
with sepsis with our blood cultures
and there's reasons for that and that's
what i'll explore in the next series of
slides
but it's also important to look for
other types of cultures that can help
guide our management of these septic
patients
anywhere from 16 to 30 percent of
patients with sepsis will have other
positive cultures like a respiratory
culture or a urine culture so it's
important to collect the right specimens
there
but still keep in mind 40 percent of the
patients have culture negative
diagnostics so our challenge is how do
we reduce that 40 percent what are the
opportunities to improve the blood
cultures and the other diagnostic tests
that we perform
now sepsis can be caused by infections
with a variety of organisms bacteria and
yeast are what we look for in blood
cultures and for most of our cultures
that's what we look for
filamentous fungi viruses and parasites
we don't look for unless we specifically
suspect those infections
so there are causes of sepsis that
unless we have a high index of suspicion
we're not going to be able to detect
them
infections associated with sepsis
include urinary tract infections which
is the most common
lower respiratory tract infections like
pneumonia which is the second most
common and then other types of
infections like meningitis
intra-abdominal infections skin and soft
tissue infections and intravascular or
catheter related infections
now if we look at each one of these
types of specimens i'm just going to
give an overview of what i think are the
challenges for urinary tract infections
what we find is about 50 of patients
have fewer than 10 to the five organisms
per milliliter of urine
so in many patients they have very low
numbers of organisms in the urine
and in a septic patient
they don't produce mature and that is
one of the one of the characteristics of
sepsis and so it's going to be
challenged to get the right specimen in
order to make the diagnosis
the number of colony forming units in
that specimen is influenced by the
pathogen
the time of day in other words how long
is the urine been in the bladder the
frequency of voiding the patient's
hydration prior antibiotic therapy all
of those can
reduce those positive urine cultures
contamination with urethral bacteria can
also complicate the interpretation of
that culture
for lower respiratory tract infections
many times of fastidious pathogen is
responsible and unless we suspect that
we won't detect it
we can have viral pathogens we saw this
with the sars covalent ii pandemic
that are responsible for for sepsis and
it can be again the specimen can be
contaminated during collection
meningitis this is an invasive specimen
the collection is an invasive procedure
if the patient has been pre-treated with
antibiotics then the success of a
spinal fluid culture is quite low and
many cases are caused by viruses or even
fungal pathogens like cryptococcus and
so unless we suspect that we're not
going to do the right diagnostic test
intra-abdominal infections are an
invasive specimen it's usually caused by
a mixture of aerobic and anaerobic
organisms as well as yeast
and skin and soft tissue infections
is potentially an invasive collection we
have to make sure we collect that
specimen at the site of where the
pathogen is located which sometimes is a
challenge
for intravascular infections or catheter
related infections many pathogens are
not recovered in the blood culture that
can include fastidious and slow growing
bacteria filamentous fungi and viruses
so we would expect unfortunately in
those cases the blood culture is not
going to be very helpful
care is required to avoid contamination
of the cultures the majority of
bacterial infections are caused by less
than one organism per milliliter of
blood
because frequently the bacteria are
diluted in the large volume of blood in
the patient or removed through the
filtering system in in the human body
therefore a positive blood culture is
directly related to how much blood is
cultured and again i'll share some
specific data to support this this
concept
positive blood cultures are also related
to the culture media that's used
and again i'll explore this in a second
and finally the presence of antibiotics
reduce the yield of a culture
the two most important variables for a
successful blood culture
is the volume of blood that's collected
and the culture media
if we focus on optimizing those two
variables
we're going to have significant better
success
with a positive with obtaining a
positive blood culture
now
what i'd like to do is look at some
pre-analytical concepts and and put all
this in in the
perspective so start off with a few
important points
most septic patients have less than one
organism per milliliter of blood and
i'll say that again most septic patients
have less than one organism per
milliliter of blood
on average most blood culture bottles
are filled with less than 25 percent
of the recommended 10 mls per bottle
so most bottles are under
filled numerous clinical studies have
demonstrated that if the blood culture
bottles were filled properly the
proportion of positive blood cultures
would be increased by 40 to 50 percent
and finally clinical studies have
demonstrated that two to three blood
cultures each consisting of two bottles
should be inoculated for optimum yield
and again let me share with you the data
that supports these comments
the first is a study of that i i pulled
together five studies
that have looked at the question
how many bacteria are circulated in the
bloodstream
when you collect that culture
and every study came up with the same
conclusion there is a significant
proportion
of blood cultures that have less than
one organism per milliliter of blood and
this is true whether it's gram positive
organisms like staph aureus
gram-negative organisms like e coli or
pseudomonas or yeast
all of these cultures had fewer or many
of these cultures had fewer than one
organism per milliliter now what does
that mean
sorry
a series of seven studies here actually
looked and asked the question
are the bibles filled properly
in other words they looked at all of the
blood culture bottles they were
receiving in their laboratory and said
how many of these are properly filled
and what we see is the vast majority of
them are not properly filled as an
example of 2018 study by cantor they
found that 20 of the adult bottles were
properly filled the last two studies
cited in this slide by chang and kahari
actually
reported the amount of blood that's
being put into the bottles and generally
is two to three milliliters of blood per
bottle not the 10 mls that's recommended
recommended only 25 percent
now
if most patients have relatively few
organisms in the bloodstream
and most bottles are under filled
what is the impact of that
and in this series of studies that's
what they looked at
um and i'll cite all the studies have
the same conclusion but let me just look
at the patel study that was reported in
2011.
in this study they collected six bottles
three cultures with two bottles each
each bottle with 10 mls of blood
and then they looked at the first bottle
with 10 mls compared to the first two
bottles and they found that with
going from 10 ml to 20 mls
they had a 25
increase in positive cultures if they
went from 10 mls to 3 bottles with a
total of 30 mls of blood it was a 35
increase
going to
four bottles or two sets of two bottles
it was a 47 or 48 percent increase
and if the full three cultures were
collected there is a 64
increase in positive blood cultures
so to pose the question
if we're going to do a blood culture
why not optimize that blood culture even
if it's a single blood culture
optimize the success of getting a
positive culture with that and that's
what these studies demonstrate by
improving the amount of blood that's
being cultured
now
just to summarize there's relatively few
organisms circulating the blood of
patients with infections
so a large volume of blood must be
cultured to get maximum number of
positive cultures
the blood cultures are consistently
underfilled so many cultures are
negative so
if we focus on how to improve what we do
the first thing is to focus on how do we
get the right amount of blood collected
even for that first blood culture
and then finally we should focus on
maximizing the value of blood cultures
by following a rule ten by two by two
that is ten mls of blood per bottle
two bottles per culture
and two cultures per patient if we
follow these guidelines
our success in getting positive blood
cultures will be significantly improved
for these septic patients
this was a study i found really very
interesting it was reported in 2019
and they directly address the question
what is the effect of antibiotics on
positive blood cultures now the
interesting thing is for this study they
were using resin bottles which are
designed to remove the presence of
antibiotics
despite that we see a significant impact
when antibiotics are administered
the red line here is at 15
15
of the bottles are positive
if you look at before antibiotics are
administered or even within an hour
after administration
in general between 25
and 30 percent of the blood cultures
were positive
but for the same patient population
after the antibiotics had been
administered and even up to 24 hours
later
there was a 50 reduction in positive
blood cultures
so even with the value of resins we
still see that there is a challenge in
getting positive blood cultures and
patients that have received antibiotics
the other point that i made at the
beginning is the importance of media and
there's four principles that i want you
to keep in mind the first is no culture
medium will support the growth of all
organisms
the second is that resin media removes
both antibiotics but it also removes
important growth nutrients
the third point is that specialized
media can enhance the recovery of
selected pathogens
and the fourth point is that a
combination of aerobic and anaerobic
media is critical
for blood cultures performed with adult
patients now again let me give a little
bit of justification for each of these
the first principle is that no cultural
media will support all organisms there's
really straightforward strict aerobic
organisms don't grow in the anaerobic
bottle
strict anaerobic organisms don't grow in
the aerobic bottle
microaerophilic and fastidious organisms
grow poorly in both of these bottles
and what we see is the
is that the combination of media will
enhance the overall recovery of
pathogens so it becomes important to use
multiple types of medium
the second is that resins remove both
antibiotics and growth
nutrients bd introduced resin media 40
years ago
and what we found is that it is
important for removing selected
antibiotics
not all antibiotics as the earlier slide
demonstrated but it is important removes
many of the antibiotics but we also know
that it removes nutrients anticoagulants
and other required growth factors and so
it's important in the manufacturing of
the media to have the right complement
of
nutrients in order to overcome
this adverse effect of the resins
i think it's important just keep in mind
that the most powerful resins that is
the ones who remove the most antibiotics
are not necessarily the best resins
because they're also are effectively
removing many of the nutrients that are
important
specialized media is also important it's
there's media that's been designed for
pediatric patients and it's not just
media in a pediatric size bottle it's
actually specific formulations for
pediatric patients to enhance the
recovery of selected pediatric pathogens
we've also seen fungal media and the
value of that is decreasing the time to
detection and improving the overall
detection of selected
fungi canada glabrata and cryptococcus
neo-formans are
probably the two best examples of this
lynic media turns out to be
significantly
what do i say this is particularly
important
because what it does is it lyses the
blood cells provides more nutrients for
the organisms to grow more
essentially better growth condition and
it decreases the background noise of the
blood cell metabolism so you get earlier
detection of organisms when they grow in
the lytic media so it's an important
complement to what we use with other
types of media
and finally the combination of aerobic
and anaerobic media is important for
adult patients
a number of studies have looked at
the
impact of anaerobic media and we see
there is improved recovery of organisms
many of these are microaerophilic
organisms like the
enterobacteriaceae like e coli
or like staphylococcus aureus and so
forth
so it's this combination of different
media that really enhance our overall
performance
if we
if we keep in mind in the principles of
a positive blood culture relatively
few organisms circulate in the
bloodstream of the septic patient
culturing an increased volume of blood
increases the likelihood of obtaining a
positive
culture and the use of multiple types of
culture media such as aerobic media
anaerobic media resin media and lytic
media
is required to optimize the value of
that blood culture
so an important question remains
what can we do
to optimize blood collection
in other words most of what i've talked
about
is the pre-analytical stuff collecting
the right volume of blood putting in the
right blood culture media in order to
optimize the efforts that occur in the
laboratory but how can we improve this
well one of the issues is to decrease
contamination of blood cultures
and that starts with the disinfectant
that's used this nice study that i've
cited here
looked at the impact of tincture of
iodine compared with chlorhexidine
alcohol
the important point is
that chlorhexidine alcohol
is able to
work much more rapidly than tendrio of
iodine
and if you
listen to the recommendations for
collecting blood cultures and then you
look at the practice frequently when
iodine is used it's not left in contact
with the skin for a sufficient period of
time and so you result in contaminated
blood cultures this study compared two
minutes potential of iodine with 15
seconds of chlorexitin which works much
faster and we see
the significant reduction in
contaminated cultures
in addition to the disinfectants it's
important to use standardized collection
protocols and kits that standardize this
collection of these important specimens
if available a dedicated phlebotomy team
has been demonstrated to improve the
overall quality of specimens that are
collected
education training monitoring and
feedback
to identify when you have a problem and
help correct that problem
all of these factors will improve the
ability to collect the appropriate blood
culture and have it not contaminated
with the skin microflora
the other thing and i'm just going to
use an example here but but it's really
a broader principle and that is look for
innovative ways to do the standard
procedures now i talked about specimen
collection
and how you can take that combination of
trained individuals that collect the
specimen using the standardized protocol
and kit
education
monitoring and feedback all of those can
improve the recovery but do you think
about other ways you can do it i'm just
using one example
uh and this is with the ultra touch uh
needle that's that's been developed by
beckham dickinson
and the difference between this and a
regular needle is that although the
outer diameter
is the same for
say this in a traditional needle
the inner diameter is much larger
because it's a thinner wall
the practical
uh aspects of this
if you look at the 23 gauge needle there
actually is a 40
increase in the size of the opening
for that needle when the
the thin wall needle if you looked at a
25 gauge needle there's a 33
increase in the opening now what does
that mean
you have a larger opening for blood to
flow through so you should be able to
collect blood more rapidly with the thin
wall needles than with the traditional
needle
again
frequently
if if you have a septic patient many
things are happening very rapidly you
want to be able to quickly
collect your cultures and so then
antibiotics can be given so this is one
aspect that helps improve the
ability to collect the appropriate
volume
of blood in a timely way
so let me
let me just conclude and say
recognizing that each clinical situation
can pose challenges
and economic conditions can limit the
availability of diagnostics
we want to make each blood culture
optimal i've traveled many countries in
the world and i know there are
challenges to collecting what the ideal
volume of blood is or the
the ideal number of cultures
so what i'm going to leave you with is
the fact that you understand the
limitations of
of diagnostics
you understand the impact of under
filling bottles or not collecting the
right number of bottles
but what you have to do
is if even if you collect a single two
bottle set
make it the best that you can collect
and optimize the percent positive blood
cultures from each single set that you
collect and i think if we do that then
we're going to see a significant
improvement in the diagnosis of sepsis
for these patients
so let me stop there i'll turn this over
to jordan and
have her presentation jordan
thank you so much
having such a great breakdown of a lot
of the diagnostic challenges we're faced
with in sepsis patients and
it's very important to recognize so many
of them are modifiable so
from from the phlebotomist hands and the
nurse's hands we can really impact the
quality of our our cultures
so i want to zoom out and expand the
conversation to the treatment challenges
the downstream treatment challenges that
can come up in sepsis patients as well i
will fill you in my background is in
emergency medicine and critical care
pharmacy so i will be referencing a lot
of my experience that i that i have
firsthand as i staff emergency
departments and icu's
so we know diagnostics and treatment
decisions go hand in hand it's often
quoted that 70
of clinical decisions are based on
information that is derived from
laboratory test results so these results
that dr murray was pointing out
areas where we can improve and ensure
the quality of those results
these objective results that come from
the lab are especially important for our
sepsis patients we know the presentation
of sepsis is quite non-specific and so
any objective clear results we can get
for the lab really do impact clinical
decisions in a profound way
so i mentioned sepsis is a particular
challenge
in terms of its non-specific
presentation therefore clinicians often
have to use a multi multi-faceted
approach to ensuring their diagnosis of
sepsis is
correct
that includes looking at the patient's
history doing a thorough physical exam
using some of the tools we have to
to combine some of the laboratory
findings and and vitals to see if
they're meeting septic criteria using
biomarkers is becoming more and more
accepted as as a tool to try to predict
our confidence level if this patient has
sepsis as well as the tried and true
cultures we know cultures are are still
mainstay of treatment and one of the
ways we can most confidently identify a
causative infection
a lot of these diagnos approaches to
diagnosis though have come with their
own challenges
the first three here the patient history
physical exam and calculation of our
sirs or qsopa scores still lead us with
a quite broad differential so they lack
some specificity
that's also true with our biomarker
tests more and more diagnostic companies
are combining biomarkers in different
ways to see if we can increase the
specificity of
of the confidence they can give us that
this patient is truly sepsis
in sepsis and
declining from a causative infection
and again we talked about cultures being
one of the mainstays of treatment here
and really helping us to objectively
identify an organ
an infection and the causative organism
of course dr murray talked about a lot
of the modifiable factors that can
impact the quality of cultures so there
there are some weaknesses with cultures
we can tackle
first cultures take time so trying to
find innovative ways to minimize your
turnaround time is always important and
then also they're susceptible to sample
collection
variability so ensuring phlebotomy
technique and and nursing training is up
to speed and whoever's collecting the
cultures understand the risks if the
cultures aren't obtained appropriately
so beyond diagnostic challenges there's
also treatment challenges and i want to
bring the patients we're impacting to
the forefront of this conversation
so some of the treatment challenges that
come with with sepsis is not every
sepsis patient looks the same it could
be a young
patient in their teens with a past
medical history of iv drug abuse
presenting with a disseminated
abscess that that finally made it into
the bloodstream
or it could be our older patient who's
been through three rounds of
chemotherapy is severely
immunocompromised and struggling with
the opportunistic infection
so every sepsis patient can look quite
different so each needs to be approached
in a patient-specific manner where we're
taking into consideration the risk and
benefits of every decision we make
customized for that patient
to inform those decisions of course it's
always important to keep in your mind
what is actually going to impact this
patient's outcomes and there's so much
literature in this space around sepsis
that i want to take us through quickly
today
on rounds
it's often
the literature that shows impacts on
mortality increases in mortality that we
reference the most and give the most
weight so i did want to also add to this
conversation some of the known risk
factors for death and sepsis that we
already have a good grasp of one is
increasing age of course that's
non-modifiable
immunodysfunction immune dysfunction is
non-modifiable unless it's a chronic
disease such as uncontrolled diabetes we
could you know assist the patient there
but for the most part if you need a
immunocompromising antibiotic due to a
past or sorry therapy due to a past
transplant for example we can't really
modify that
delays and receipt of effective
antimicrobials is linked to
impacting mortality in these patients as
well as associated lung injury
so so for purposes of today i really
want to bring attention to this
modifiable bullet delays in receipt of
effective antimicrobials is truly
life-saving
and it's a very time sensitive
matter
so the surviving sepsis guidelines
published and updated at the end of last
year really help us break down the whole
picture of what's going to impact
outcomes to inform our patient-specific
approaches
they start by talking about performance
improvement programs and they emphasize
the importance of always re-evaluating
your processes your techniques your
your
your phlebotomy teams and your
pre-analytical as well as your teams in
the micro labs our knowledge of of
proper technique and culture culture
processing they do talk about it though
in a more broad approach of general
sepsis bundles which dr murray took us
through but i did i do want to emphasize
cultures here i will tell you
practicing in emergency departments we
focus on a decompensating sepsis patient
and the time sensitivity of antibiotics
but i have noticed a lack of focus on
timing of cultures
technique around those cultures and
setting ourselves up for downstream
success to be able to make decisions off
of accurate and efficiently drawn
cultures
so that should be something we're all
aware of i think from a
multi-disciplinary approach so we can
prioritize cultures and then hang
antibiotics in a timely manner the new
guidelines actually do
emphasize if there's ambiguity in the
patient so it's not a clearly septic
shock patient with with a clear history
of infection and we know this is a
decline due to infection
you know even putting more weight on the
importance of drawing cultures and
drawing them appropriately and
thoroughly before getting antibiotics on
board as pat slides showed we have up to
three hours in those more ambiguous not
clearly septic shock patients so this
can impact mortality and you can see the
odds ratio here on the slide can impact
mortality by up to 40
so sepsis is a time sensitive manner
and matter and
here i i spell out some of the other
time-sensitive manners we come across in
our emergency departments including
major traumas stemis and strokes
we do want to encourage sepsis to begin
to be thought about in this way
get getting time
getting your minimizing your time to
antibiotics in these patients especially
if they're really declined is crucial
but doing it in a thoughtful way that
we're not ignoring the importance of
cultures and setting our success
ourselves up for success of optimizing
those antibiotics down the line
so appropriate cultures what is an
appropriate culture often we think about
the laboratory the culture is being sent
to and some of the tools that are being
used in that lab i have pictured here a
continuous blood culture monitoring
system as well as software that can be
used to relay those results
but as dr murray so eloquently spelled
out pre-analytical factors and decisions
could influence the quality of our
cultures just as much
and so
proper antisepsis prior to obtaining a
blood culture proper selection of the
needle and use of a needle and transfer
device system as well as proper
selection of media are crucial
and then of course i've emphasized this
a lot i'm a pharmacist so i'm very
passionate about this this concept but
time to appropriate empiric antibiotics
can be life-saving
we know if empiric antibiotics are
started early and they're correct
if it's a really septic patient so
decline septic shock with hemodynamic
instability some studies have shown
mortality risk decreases by up to seven
percent every hour other studies where
they're less severe have shown increases
closer to one percent per hour either
way these are these are impacting
risk of death which is huge
also the sooner we can get antibiotics
on the sooner we can try to prevent
further nosocomial spread between our
patients and and
introducing more organisms into the
hospital
if incorrect of course mortality is
gonna mortality risk is gonna continue
to increase which is very concerning for
again those more progressive progressed
septic shock patients and risk of
nosocomial spread remains because you're
not covering covering the organism and
lastly you are exposing that patient to
antibiotics where their organisms can
actually
um and i'm sorry i don't know if that
slide was being pushed to you but
um
where you're exposing patients to
antibiotics so their organisms have a
chance to begin to learn and to develop
resistance
so how are we doing with our empiric
antibiotic selection
there's some recent literature that
shows we need to be paying more
attention to this as inappropriate
antibiotic use has actually gone up
during the pandemic
you can see here with three waves of
cobit the first on the left being
epsilon then delta then omicron with
each peak we see significant increases
in third and fourth generation
cephalosporins
well as macrolides
and this is very understandable because
i will tell you a respiratory decline
that came into the hospital over the
past few years it's hard to justify not
putting on antibiotics because it's hard
to differentiate viral from bacterial
pneumonia
but the appropriateness
this still should be done thoughtfully
and the appropriateness
assessed
so there's been some internal research
done actually by some colleagues here at
bd that i'm really excited to share with
you today special thanks to dr vikas
gupta and calvin yu
but if i can bring your attention to the
table here on the right and the fourth
row down that's highlighted in blue i
want to point out our covet patients
here in this row if they had a co
bacterial infection that didn't have
resistance so it's one of our common
pneumonia organisms we were getting
empiric therapies right about 75 percent
of the time
if any antimicrobial resistance was
present in that patient our appropriate
empiric antibiotic decisions went down
to about 60 percent of the time or 65
63
and if they had multi drug resistance
against microbial resistance we were
about 50 50
in our
our accurate guesses on empiric
antibiotic therapy so it's so important
to not only start antibiotics early but
really do it thoughtfully because if
we're not doing it thoughtfully we could
be worsening amr and we aren't
decreasing that patient's risk of
mortality
so of course your risk of getting it
wrong increases with amr as that data
shows
but how can we fix this how can we get
these as correct as possible well
straight off the bat with empiric
therapy we're never going to get it
perfect 100 but it's super important to
make sure we're diving into the
patient's past medical history past
cultures and trying to inform those
antibiotic decisions and then
fortunately the point of of our slides
today
and i'm sorry let me make sure i'm
pushing this to you
sorry so i'm so i was saying how can we
fix this and get 100 of our imperial
antibiotic
decisions correct
and so besides diving into their past
medical histories we have tools and we
have tools that we can use in a more
optimal way and i want to encourage us
bringing more and more attention to the
quality and use of our diagnostics
this will take some collaboration with
our pre-analytical teams but also our
decision-making teams on the back end
once these results are reported so if
pharmacy or the id teams can respond
more quickly to the initial gram scene
we are
impacting potentially mortality if the
teams can respond
quickly to that first id off let's say
they use multi
we are impacting mortality and then of
course
being able to have full confidence in
our antimicrobial susceptibility tests
to ensure the most accurate and narrow
therapy
we are possibly impacting mortality in
these sepsis patients so in summary i
just thought it was really helpful to
break down these guidelines and bring
our patients to the forefront of this
conversation and the importance of
diagnostics we should always be trying
to implement new performance improvement
programs
around our diagnostics to ensure we're
always optimizing our technique and our
knowledge of the consequences of if our
technique isn't appropriate we need to
make sure we're always acting fast
we need to ensure our cultures are done
appropriately this in and of itself has
shown mortality benefit in short we are
optimizing our instrumentation and
really trying to optimize turnaround
time as well as quality and positivity
rates off of our cultures
and then lastly that we're relaying the
results to the treatment decision teams
in a timely manner and that they are
responding in a time timely manner so
this really is an interdisciplinary
effort and i want to ask you today how
can we close the gap between our
pre-analytical teams our laboratory
personnel and our treatment teams
because this is is a multi-faceted issue
that we want to bring more attention to
diagnostics and really again this is all
with the goal
to improve sepsis patient outcomes
and i want to leave
today
with
proposing a question to you whether your
role is down in the microbiology lab
usually that's down but sometimes it's
up and um or if you're the
pre-analytical team so nursing and
phlebotomy and or part of the the
antibiotic decision making teams what
can you do to narrow these gaps between
our teams and ensure we're all aware of
diagnostic
optimization opportunities in our
hospitals that will impact sepsis
patient outcomes
so thank you so much for your time today
and again thank you dr murray so much
for your breakdown of some of the
diagnostic challenges and approaches we
can take
we'll go ahead and start
our q a portion of this um presentation
there's dr murray perfect thank you
so if you have questions and you're
attending right now
if you'd like to ask them now please do
so again just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
so we're looking forward to hearing your
questions and we'll get started now
so first question for you dr murray we'd
love to pick your brain on
you mentioned the variability that can
exist in positivity rates we obtained
from blood cultures as well as
contamination rates so do you have
advice on how we can assess the
significance of a positive blood culture
so it's an interesting question um
and maybe because of my age i can cite
literature that's probably
published before some of you were born
but in the 1990s there are some really
very nice studies that i think are still
relevant today and they they were
performed by
mel weinstein arthraler and and a group
uh and what they did it was two separate
studies and each one looked
at
500 patients with positive blood
cultures
and then they made a clinical assessment
of the significance of the positive
isolates
and probably it shouldn't be a surprise
but
if if you looked at the recovery of
staph aureus in a blood culture about 75
percent of those patients turned out to
have significant uh isolates
and at that time and again remember this
is in the 1990s uh less than 10 percent
of the patients with coagulase negative
staphylococci
had significant cultures i think that's
changed dramatically
in our hospitals today with
use of
iv lines and
prosthetic devices such as heart valves
and so forth so the percent
significant quantity is negative
bacteremias is probably higher than what
it was in that study
if you look the gram-negative bacteria
the
e coli klebsiella all the gram negatives
almost all of those were significant
except for some of the non-fermenters
some
pseudomonas species other than the
rigidosa
but in general if it's a gram-negative
it's going to be clinically significant
the same was true for yeast infections
if you isolate yeast and blood that's
almost always clinically significant so
i think we can use that as a general
guideline
but it's always a clinical assessment
when you look at the patient and you
have to make the physician who's taking
care of that patient has to balance that
with the
isolate that you have
i think in the microbiology laboratory
because we have the ability to
identify organisms much better than what
we could historically
moving from biochemical testing to
the use of
maldi-tof
we're able to identify organisms that
many times the physician hasn't heard of
before and so one of our
responsibilities
is to understand the significance of
that organism it's its association with
infections and be able to
educate our physicians
about that so
again a challenge for the laboratories
now that we can identify organisms
maybe a
more sophisticated way than what we've
done historically
absolutely and another opportunity to
collaborate between the lab and the and
the decision making team to ensure
it's a very informed decision so thank
you for that break it breakdown
we talked about the importance of
minimizing turnaround times and ensuring
both accuracy but also efficiency for
cultures so
where have you seen in your in your
patient care experience the most
significant delays in being able to
relay positive results to the treatment
team
you know from from a microbiology
laboratory perspective we've always
focused on how fast does the organism
grow in the incubator
and we
try to understand the significance of
one hour faster growth and one type of
culture system versus another
and i think that's important to be aware
of that but that's not where the
problems are
the problems start in
taking that posit i'm sorry taking that
blood culture that's collected on the
floor
and getting it into the laboratory
and the studies that have looked at this
have shown that there are delays up to
15 hours particularly in emergency
departments and in highly busy areas
like icu's those cultures may be
collected but if they sit there in the
nurses station and don't get delivered
to the laboratory
we have a significant problem even under
root routine conditions there's
typically a three four five hour delay
before the coaches get there and if
they're collected in the evening it may
be a number of hours before it's
actually put into the incubator
the other area where i see significant
delays is
the blood culture signals positive in
your instrument
but it's not taken out of the instrument
and worked up
many times the laboratory don't
prioritize that positive blood cultures
now in some cases it's because
a significant proportion become positive
when nobody's in the laboratory
you know and that's something that
should be addressed for those
laboratories how can they prioritize
that positive that comes up at three in
the morning
and in other cases they prioritize that
we will look at and work up that
positive blood cultures at certain
periods during the day they don't do it
when it becomes positive but there may
be a delay of three four five six hours
before it's worked out
so if we really want to reduce
the amount of time it takes we have to
focus on first understanding where the
delays are in getting the bottles into
the laboratory and then where are the
delays in
the laboratory prioritizing the workup
and reporting
of those positive cultures
i think if we master that then we can
look at
i think what much less
significant delays such as how long does
it take for that bottle to grow in the
incubator
great thank you so much for that
breakdown
uh we got another question here
um that is how should we collect
cultures when we have an open system
such as syringes should we change
syringes between putting blood first
into the anaerobic bottle and then into
the aerobic bottle do you have advice on
this
um
so there are studies that have looked at
the value of changing the needle so and
some some
thoughts were that
the needle may be contaminated so remove
the needle replace it with a sterile
needle and then inject the the blood
culture bottles that turns out in my
opinion to be a very dangerous practice
and in the studies that have been
reported with
almost no exceptions the
almost no exceptions they've
demonstrated no value in changing that
needle so i wouldn't do that
um
in
inoculated inoculation of the aerobic
bottle then the anaerobic bottle i mean
that's the recommendations i have never
seen the study that may exist but i'm
not aware of a study that has shown
there is a difference between which
bottles you inoculate first
my opinion and i emphasize this in my
presentation
focus on the volume of blood you collect
and worry about those other details a
little bit less
i think also as i said
uh
try to be careful of not doing things
that may be dangerous
it's an interesting concept collecting
specimens with a syringe
i said in my presentation
the optimum amount of blood
is eight to ten milliliters of blood per
bottle and two bottles per culture
that means you'd have to have a 20 ml
syringe but virtually nobody
on the floors would use a 20 ml syringe
to collect blood
so in my opinion i think the use of
syringes
is now contraindicated
i think a needle set makes much more
sense for for blood collection
great
um we have another
question here that expands to to
diagnostic options for for
minimizing turnaround time so
the rate limiting step in detecting
bacteria is cultivation of bacteria from
the blood even with some of our
molecular technologies that have come
out
he specifically is wondering systems
like t2 biosystems of directing uh
detecting organisms directly from the
blood is one option that's tried to
tackle this but what's your experience
in real life of of trying to um
eliminate or is it worth eliminating the
cultivation step or is there not going
to be a
a way around that essentially
um
i don't think
i think we'll be real practical i don't
see blood cultures
being replaced by any technology
in the short term
we all hope
that there'll be a molecular tool that
will allow very rapid direct detection
of organisms in the bloodstream
the challenges that we all recognize is
that there's very few organisms
circulating in the blood so you need
some way of concentrating those
organisms in order to optimize
your positive test result
um
you know i worked
for 10 plus years with beckham dickinson
we had we worked in this issue
every day
and i think we we all appreciated the
fact that it's a real challenge and i
would say anybody
you know in
my capacity and other companies would
also admit the same thing so
um
our hope is that we'll have a new
technology
um i'm a bit pessimistic i don't think
we're gonna see it
uh
in the near future near future five to
ten years i think there are
culture techniques like t2 the example
that you gave
is a complementary
tool
i don't think it will replace the blood
cultures at least currently not yet
great thank you so much for that input
one more question here i think we have
we'll we'll keep tr
jugging through these um for as long as
we can so one more is should we use peas
bottles only for adults patients who we
can't draw optimal blood volumes from
yeah i think i think it's a challenge if
you introduce pediatric bottles and say
it can be used for those
particular adult patients
my experience is that they become the
standard of care
and that really
goes against what what i talked about
before the importance of volume
it is interesting we
we did a series of studies uh internally
where we
looked at
what happens if you under fill a bottle
um
and it it turns out that there's not a
dramatic impact on that
so i would still use the
uh the adult size bottles for adults
even if you don't
add the full eight or ten mls because we
recognize certain patients you can't do
that their veins collapse they're
they may be adults but
you know they weigh less than 100 pounds
it's going to be very difficult to
collect uh the amount of blood that
we're we're recommending
that's why i said that if
if you can only collect one blood
culture make it the best blood culture
you can collect so to
absolutely optimize the result of that
single blood culture the recommendation
is to collect multiple blood cultures
but do the best you can with what you're
able to do but i wouldn't use pediatric
bottles in adult patients because i
think it's just going to lead
sort of to bad practices
overall
and and i'll just say i
i don't look at prices or anything but i
i suspect the cost of a pediatric bottle
is about the same cost as an adult
bottle
so
unless i'm completely wrong i don't
think you're going to save money doing
it that way either so that's not a
justification
yep you're right about the costs um
the cost is very dependent on if it
contains resin or not and both
usually the peeds bottles have resin as
well as the adult
aerobic bottles have have resin so those
costs will be very similar
um thank you for that
um let me see it if we have more you
have received a lot of thank you so
thank you again dr
murray
um there's one more interesting question
i think i think we'll have to before and
then the rest of these we can respond to
you directly using the email you
register stirred with so this one's
really interesting since sepsis is
basically a dysregulated host response
to an infection
what role does it do immuno modulators
play in the management of sepsis
oh
i'm not
you know jordan i'm not sure i'm the
right person to answer that because i
don't follow that literature carefully
um
it's actually too bad we don't have a
physician that was
on on this call because i think that
would be more
a medical question i used to tell my my
fellows when i was training them whether
it's the nih or wherever
that they don't practice medicine from
the laboratory
um you really have to see the patient
understand the patient to to know how to
manage that patient so when they were
always asked for medical advice i said
never give medical advice unless you're
going to go with a physician and see the
patient
so
that's sort of a modification of
this
i don't feel comfortable answering that
question
yeah absolutely um thank you so much
again dr murray i think i think that's
all the questions we're going to have
time for today we really appreciate all
your attendance and your involvement in
the q a
and we look forward to any follow-up
questions we might receive and and thank
you again for attending this
presentation will be available on demand
demand after this live session is
complete and you will receive a link to
that in the email you provided
so thank you again everyone and feel
free to forward that link to anyone who
may have missed today's live event
until next time
uh we hope we see oh yeah yeah jordan i
like to also thank everybody i enjoyed
the opportunity i sort of missed this i
did it for so many years
um i hope that what we presented was was
useful
um i always would sort of in my
presentations by challenging the
audience
to take what they learned today
and make one change do one thing
different than what they were doing
yesterday that's going to improve what
you do whether it's what you do in the
laboratory what you do in the
pre-analytical site what you do and
managing patients but take something
from this instead of just absorbing the
knowledge
and apply it to a patient and help that
patient and i think if you do that then
we've been successful in this
presentation so again thank you to the
audience
thank you so much everyone thanks
you